one curse of being a youtuber is that
anytime I mentioned a product a game
I've worked at before
everyone assumes I'm only mentioning
again because I was sponsored by them
like last year I gave this sponsored
shout-out to this game Shadow verse but
it's a game I got so into that I've
logged over 200 hours of my Steam
account which actually isn't even half
the total amount of playtime I've put
into it because I mainly play on my
phone and a few months ago I even
managed to reach Grand Master rank in it
now
I don't know many people who play it so
of course I'm going to use every chance
I get to mention it to my friends or
tweeting about it on Twitter but every
time I do everyone makes the same
[ __ ] joke is this a sponsored video
hashtag ads alright so do I check the
description use coupon code Giga Caswell
oh yeah nice sponsor tweet there Giga
look alright I didn't literally put
hundreds of hours in the game just for
you to make the same snarky joke I've
heard a million times before every time
I mention it I just like the game okay
by the way this video is sponsored by
shadow bus
[Music]
yes welcome to my first ever dedicated
video sponsor which I finally decided to
take up cuz of reasons but honest to god
I've wanted to talk about shadow verse
for a while because being an
english-speaking shadow verse play is
kind of like so first things first what
is Shadow verse shutter verse is a
strategic turn-based massively
multiplayer online story driven via
visual novel RPG experience a card game
are you [ __ ] blind it's a bloody card
game alright but Giga isn't this an
anime channel why would I are we be
interested in Shadow verse what's in it
for me you serious do I do I really need
to spell out for you it's all about that
waifu's now I've had to take a few
months off and play in the game recently
because of a hell I just threw myself
into so my ranks been reset and I'm
completely out of touch with the current
meta but that's fine no big deal I'm
sure I can still show a newbie like you
how to become a true master of the game
like any other card game you have to
create today this time of exactly 40
cards in one of the 8 unique classes to
choose from the caters to different
strategic play stars designed by some of
the best card game players in the world
there you go that was a paragraph of
influenced buzzwords I was told to say
in my brief dragon craft is about
summoning a bunch of powerful monsters
way earlier than you normally allow to
cause screw the rules I have dragon
Oracle voice Croft is about using a
bunch of low cost fairies to do your
bidding Haven craft is [ __ ] [ __ ]
if I see quell one more [ __ ] toy
craft has a lot of cards with sword
users I don't know what you're expecting
shadow craft is honestly I don't get
shadowgraph they [ __ ] suck at playing
shadow craft blood kroff is all about
living dangerously keeping your health
low for powerful effects Porter craft is
when you want to feel like you have 200
IQ planning ten steps ahead playing ten
times as smart as your opponent and then
still losing the game
and finally rune craft fair cards that
combo each other for no skill players
who just wants easy wins
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm just kidding
you play rune crafts you can stare at
Isabel's spell boosted knockers Tunney
be all this information may sound
daunting but don't worry honestly the
best way to learn this game initially is
just to play through the story yes this
game has a story that's fully voiced in
both English and Japanese now I know
you're thinking oh it's just an anime
card gamer but it's not even worth
playing
it's probably just some generic
save-the-world anime [ __ ] plot we've
seen a million times before and well
I'll have you know that you're
absolutely correct in the first two
chapters but don't worry cuz then
chapter 3 hits and the story takes a
huge leap in quality when it becomes a
nice akai I wish it wasn't this easy to
get me invested no but for real though
father would seem of eight years as the
ISA Kai their way to multiple worlds
struck could not included from a guild
world to a mecha world to a forest world
encountering a cast of wide and wacky
characters from best Sundari Elinor and
a talking cat virus why is there just an
Irish talking cat show diverse please I
need answers it actually kind of
blindsided behind best I got eight
points especially during the highlight
of the entire story so far the one reach
where becomes a buddy cop show pairing
an all-powerful super serious immortal
vampire with a sarcastic Mecca big titty
or nazar move on sure your eius is
scored here's the unsympathetic see
that's the thing every part of this
game's design is practically made for
modern weaves and I'm not just talking
about the waifu's from the look to the
feel I mean one of the previous
expansion packs themes was an ESA kite
Ottoman tog let me just repeat that an e
Sakai tournament Ark quiz densely that
happened to be the season where each
Grand Master now the cards in shadow
verse come in four tiers
bronze silver gold and legendary there
you get by opening card packs with
legendary cards being the strongest and
rarest ones that you can get oh god no
please like I'll do this
luckily though if you're missing
specific cards then you can just learn
your extra cards for vials that you can
use to craft the cards that you need so
you don't have to sync hundreds of
dollars trying to draw for a specific
card to complete your deck yeah that's
right draw rates go suck a dick ha ha ha
oh no where take let's kick up with so
many cars to choose from how can I a
mere mortal even begin to start forming
my own decks against other people well
my young padawan you see once you
trained enough learning all the
different classes put hundreds of hours
playing against every deck every player
you can unlock the secret technique
known only to the most skilled of shadow
burst players and that's called checking
the updated tier list and just copying
the most meta decks look at this guy's
strategizing multiple counters wind
conditions and card combos going full
tryhard modes and then there's a true
master like me now witness the superior
tactics a play one can reduce their max
health by 5 and my turn I play 2
calories reduce their max health by 5
and my turn and then for my epic
finishing move I play three Carol's
reduced their max self by five who has a
bonus protection 5 damage to the enemy
directly and that ladies and gentlemen
is what we call GG outplayed but don't
worry if that wasn't enough riveting
gameplay for you how about one of the
decks I love to play against the
whirlwind Roche dead did I say love I
meant [ __ ] good test because this
deck accurately recreates the experience
of trying to deal with an actual roach
infestation I mean just look at this
card a one play point one attack one
defense but that's so fragile you can
probably kill it by giving it to mildly
intimidating stare but before you have
the chance to just scurries away back to
the safety of the opponents hand out of
sights the only place where bug spray
can't reach it but every time that
happens its attack increases by one and
then after it attacks over five you can
just directly attack you so you can do
nothing but listen to this [ __ ] ear
piercing screech over and over that's
just like
let me just [ __ ] kill with you in one
time this is like some guerilla warfare
tactics which makes it all the more
frustrating that it's a virtual card
game so you can't just hard counter it
by physically slapping the cards out of
your opponent's hand so you can just oh
yeah how this is stupid but not so tough
now you don't handle it now unlike other
online games that can be filled with
toxicity thanks to the voice or texture
you just don't get that shadow verse see
the only way you can interact with each
other is just by selling these cute
little emotes that can be sent up to
three times a ton you see there's no
negative gaming here no name-calling no
arguing all you get is a few lines of
pre-programmed dialogue per turn I mean
it's not how is anyone gonna get mad at
that you can't get tilted it's
impossible to get tilted how could
anyone get tilted that's some stupid
little emo oh you think you're hot [ __ ]
do you know I'm just gonna pause it
there for a quick PSA remember one of
the most important things when playing
shadow verse is your mentality see when
you win you need to understand it was
all complete skill it was all plans you
are played your opponent you understand
the game better you're just a [ __ ]
god but if your opponent wins he's a
piece of [ __ ] he just got lucky you
didn't draw the cards you need he's
probably just a mindless sheep lame
dopey meta deck wise mocking a bloody
even better again
he's probably not even having fun I mean
how can you be having fun if you're
winning with that deck that's not even
the wire it's have fun he's my evening
having fun you know what they say if you
can't beat them join them what a loser
he was actually trying oh but he wasn't
even having fun now I know one of your
biggest concerns is that you don't want
to be duped into getting into a game to
spend [ __ ] tons of money and I know this
is a sponsored video so you have to take
everything with a grain of salt but to
remind her that this is from sigh games
the developers of the one gotcha game in
my gotcha game video I didn't spend any
money on one of their main selling
points they tell every sponsor to say is
that by completing the tutorial he gets
50 free card packs which sounds like a
lot but I'm here to say that's actually
just the start
you play the story money for packs you
beat the hardest AI decks money for
packs daily missions money for packs
login rewards money for packs by just
simply playing the game consistently you
get enough resources to craft
three or four strong meta decks every
new expansion there's even the system
called temporary cards where you
essentially just get free legendre
cards that you can use in every game
mode and never disappear so I don't even
know why they're called temporary cards
you're just getting free legendaries
there's nothing temporary about it god
I'm so [ __ ] good in this game you
look at this what are you gonna do you
got to health I've got full health what
were you gonna do just you play your
last pathetic card
and that's basically shadow verse look
for real though this is the first card
game I've ever gotten into you and I
really enjoy it my school never had that
card game phase and the other big ones
never had that thing that just drew me
in which is why to me as a weeb but this
was just the perfect gateway game no
Tony is every part of this game made to
appeal to modern weebs but it's actually
just a straight-up good card game
according to many card game veterans
I've talked to including my own editor
who I got to try it out and might have
ended up spending more time playing the
game than actually editing this video
our rudy is very free-to-play frensley
and you know what even if I wasn't
working with them I'd honestly be happy
if more people just played the game
because the english-speaking community
of this outside of Asia is tiny and you
know what it would be cool for me if
more people just knew about it
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again - shadow verse for
sponsoring me today look I know I've dug
my own grave - the sponsor joke but
that's fine
I'll take it I'll take you if we just go
play the game I just want more friends
to play the game okay how difficult it
is to complete your daily missions doing
private matches when you have zero
friends who play the game yeah if you
want to try it out click the link in the
description to download it on Steam or
on your mobile and yes I know I've been
doing a wide variety of content recently
I hope you've been enjoying it don't
worry I haven't forgotten about doing
anime content as I said before I just
wanted to take a short break from anime
but the new season is starting now so um
yeah I've got to get back on that train
pretty soon I have actually been
enjoying doing all sorts of different
things though it's been nerve-racking
for me because I'm not used to it at all
so if you enjoy the contents and I hope
you enjoy what I do in the future
because honestly doing more stuff
outside of just pure anime content on my
channel has been some of the most fun
I've had doing work for a while anyway
though that's it from me
I've been giga and i will see you all
next time and Shadow verse what did you
do to sort brah I don't need another
sword craft meta